snapchat is one of the most popular
social media platforms in the world
especially amongst gen z
in fact amongst many teenagers and young
adults snap has become a verb similar to
google or venmo yet despite their
popularity like most tech companies and
startups they lost money for most of
their life
in fact the last quarter of 2021 was the
first profitable quarter in the
company's history as a public company
snapchat proudly announced this news
near the top of their quarterly report
likely with optimistic expectations for
the stock
yet it's been months since this report
came out and snapchat stock is still
doing worse than ever before
since their peak in september of 2021
snapchat fell a total of 70
which correlates to a market cap loss of
95.8 billion
or nearly 100 billion dollars
they have recovered a substantial amount
over the past several weeks rallying
over 50
but even with this significant rally
they're still down over 50 percent from
their all-time high so what happened to
snapchat
taking a look back such terrible stock
performance is unfortunately not new to
snapchat in fact for most of snapchat's
public life their stock price has
performed horrendously for example right
after snapchat set an all-time high
following their ipo they proceeded to
crash 83 percent and this wasn't some
quick three or four month crash like the
covet crash either this was a long and
drawn out sellout that lasted nearly two
years
by the time the sell-off ended snapchat
was literally a penny stock coming in at
less than five dollars per share
this wasn't to say that snapchat was
fundamentally performing bad though
in fact snapchat is yet to even have a
single negative quarter in terms of
revenue growth nonetheless it seems like
investors don't want any part of
snapchat and that brings us into
snapchat's first shortfall which is a
lack of a strong investor base despite
being on the market for over five years
now snapchat has struggled to attract
investors because they lack a
differentiating factor
now users of snapchat would likely
disagree with this statement given that
despite facebook and youtube's best
attempts to replicate the best features
of snapchat like stories most snapchat
users have preferred to continue using
snapchat for specific use cases
it seems like snapchat has mastered
casual conversations better than any of
their competitors but from an investor's
perspective who cares if snapchat
fulfills some niche role within young
adults lives on paper instagram is
superior in almost every way
for example in terms of demographics 18
to 24 year olds are snapchat's biggest
customer base and 13 to 17 year olds
make up nearly a quarter of their user
base meanwhile instagram's largest
demographic is 25 to 34 year olds with
second place going to 18 to 24 year olds
instagram's 13 to 17 year old base is
almost non-existent while the 35 years
knock demographic is actually quite
substantial if newer generations don't
switch over to using instagram that
could be a long-term problem but for the
time being instagram has no shortage of
users and all of their users are
significantly older than snapchat users
which means that they have more money
are more monetizable and are of course
more profitable this directly aligns
with household income studies conducted
on both platforms as well snapchat use
is most common amongst households with
income between 70 and 80 000 per year
meanwhile instagram use is most common
amongst households with incomes above
100 000 per year
again users with more money equals more
profits
something else to note about snapchat's
demographics is that it's mostly just
limited to the us
snapchat has 109.5 million users within
the us which is nearly more than all of
the users in all these countries
combined
if we take a look at instagram's usage
by country we can clearly see that it's
a lot more spread out especially amongst
emerging countries so from an investor's
perspective there's very little reason
to bet on snapchat over facebook if you
want to target millennials and older
instagram is the way to go
if you want to target people with money
instagram is the way to go
and if you want to target emerging
countries instagram is the way to go
the only reason to invest in snapchat is
if you think that younger generations in
the us will continue to use snapchat
over instagram which could very well be
true
but for this to become a financial
advantage for snapchat we'll likely have
to wait another 5-10 years at the very
least and in the meantime snapchat will
likely remain the underdog amongst
investors
aside from snapchat's unlucrative
demographic snapchat was also hit hard
with apple's privacy changes that rolled
out last year
if you guys aren't aware of this yet in
april of 2021 apple rolled out a feature
called the app tracking transparency
this feature allows users to choose if
they want to let third-party apps
collect data regarding their usage for
advertising purposes
and as you would guess basically
everyone opted out
according to this study only four
percent of americans were opting into
tracking and i have a feeling that a lot
of these guys may have accidentally
pressed allow snapchat's ceo evan
spiegel was actually a big proponent of
this move
in fact he believes that these privacy
changes were good for iphone consumers
and the social media ecosystem in
general
but despite his moral support for the
change this change was obviously not
good for snapchat's financials in
october of 2021 evan announced that
apple's privacy changes have actually
been affecting revenue more than they
originally anticipated and to make
things worse snapchat failed to meet
investors already conservative revenue
estimates which of course sent the stock
tumbling given this unfavorable
situation evan has chosen to focus on
profitability which he did accomplish
but this has left many investors
wondering at what cost sure it's nice to
invest in a profitable company but the
primary reason most snapchat investors
made the investment was because of
growth expectations and it now it seems
like evan is trying to piece investors
with profits instead of growth snapchat
doesn't have a p e ratio quite yet as
that requires a full year of
profitability but even if we take their
net income of 22.55 million dollars from
last quarter and extrapolated to a year
we only get about 100 million dollars
now this isn't a bad amount by any means
but compared to the market cap this
gives them a pe ratio of 673
even if we say that snapchat's
profitability grows to 250 million
dollars per quarter or 10x from where
they currently are their pe ratio would
still be quite high at 67.3 to put that
in perspective facebook's pe ratio is
under 20. this isn't exactly a bad thing
given that snapchat should theoretically
have a lot more growth left than
facebook but that's the key they need to
have growth and with apple's privacy
policy changes and potentially more on
the way investors aren't quite convinced
to give snapchat even more credit
at this point you may be thinking what
could possibly be worse than having
slower growth and a less profitable user
base
well the answer is being replaced
but wait a minute snapchat has a massive
user base most of whom are young so
snapchat won't be going anywhere anytime
soon right
well while that may be true that doesn't
prevent an old or new competitor from
overtaking snapchat
just take a look at tick tock tick tock
wasn't released till september of 2016
yet it was the most visited site in the
world in 2021
this isn't to say that it's easy to
replicate tick-tock success but it makes
it clear that the barrier for entry is
extremely low within the social media
industry from an app development
perspective it's not particularly hard
to create a social media app what's hard
is garnering users and 99.999
of social media apps will never garner
the same user base of snapchat or
facebook but from snapchat's perspective
only one or two of the millions of
social media apps out there need to
catch on for snapchat to lose user
engagement to these new apps and from a
user's perspective if a new better app
comes out the only thing stopping you
from switching over is your friends also
switching over
if your social circle switches over
you'll probably never look back and this
has been shown time and time again
within the social media industry
first there was friendster then there
was myspace then we had facebook and
twitter and after that we had instagram
and whatsapp and now we have snapchat
what's to say that snapchat won't
eventually be phased out as well
well the truth is that all companies are
eventually phased out it's just that the
phase at the top is rather short-lived
for social media companies due to the
low barrier of entry like apple for
example they also won't stay at the top
forever but think about how much more
difficult it is for a company to come
out with a smartphone and convince you
to pay several hundred dollars for it as
opposed to an app developer coming out
with a social media app and convincing
you to give it a shot obviously the
latter is magnitudes easier which is
great for competition and evolution but
not great for investors for example just
take a look at twitter stock they really
haven't moved in nearly a decade not to
mention it twitter has become
unprofitable once again and jack dorsey
has left the company
really the only social media stock that
has performed extremely well
historically is facebook and that's
mainly thanks to the acquisitions of
whatsapp and instagram also something to
note about facebook is that while they
have performed well financially they're
one of the most hated if not demoted
company in the world
so i don't think that's necessarily
something that snapchat should strive
for but at the same time if they don't
make acquisitions and become the big
tech company that everyone hates it's
just a matter of time until the new kid
on the block overtakes them anyway
while this video has mostly pointed out
the shortfalls of snapchat and the
social media industry i don't think
snapchat is going anywhere anytime soon
they just became profitable their user
base is just starting to make money and
there's still plenty of user growth left
for snapchat so i don't think snapchat
has really hit their stride yet meaning
that snapchat stock likely has a lot of
upside ahead but with that being said i
don't think snapchat is a lifelong hold
like many other investments such as the
s p 500 tesla bitcoin ethereum etc
whether snapchat peaks at a market cap
of 300 billion dollars or market cap of
a one trillion dollars i think it's just
a matter of time until they're phased
out and i think the next wave of facing
will be extremely painful i think the
next phase will not only be a move away
from snapchat but a move away from
traditional social media in general
with more people being aware of how
these companies make money and
increasing concern for privacy and more
backlash than ever before against big
tech i think it's highly likely that the
next big social media app will be some
sort of decentralized or non-profit
endeavor like signal i suspect mark
zuckerberg has similar beliefs and
that's why he cut back on social media
acquisitions and debating it all on the
metaverse with that being said i think
an investment into snapchat would be
more of a median horizon investment of
10 to 15 years you may be able to get in
make a solid 10x and get out but in my
opinion if you're gonna commit to a
stock for 10 to 15 years why not commit
to something that you can hold on to
life that can produce a 30 40 or 50x
return but that's just what i think
would you guys invest in snapchat
comment that down below
also drop a like if you use snapchat and
of course consider checking out our
international channels to watch their
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to more questions logically
answered but until then i'm hari and
i'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]